well it's so good to see you thank you
for joining us
how's it how's it 2020 being my 2020
started totally normal in January I went
to Paris did my interview for the
fashion week there came back to Beijing
on January 22nd and finding things a
little bit tense because there were a
lot of rumors having lived through stars
I wasn't that concerned and on the 23rd
I had a friend of mine from New York
come to my house who had a flu and we
had dinner together and another friend
who came who left the next day for
Australia for vacation on an airplane so
we were not taking this terribly
seriously until there was a lockdown and
we've seen that echo around the world I
think still some people find it hard to
understand the magnitude of some of the
measures that China took I mean what
else are we missing about China's
response in all of this you know
historically we're just such a two very
different countries in terms of culture
and history I mean these are two
completely different human experiences
for its people
so for China when the lockdown how it
happens people are okay people are okay
with it because they think that's what a
good parent should do you know if a kid
gets sick sick you put him in the other
room and you lock him up and make sure
that the other kids don't get sick and
they expect that out of the government
but when it is outside of China from
America it becomes a huge issue of the
right political thing to do and whether
it's infringing on personal freedom so
the issues
you have to deal with in the democratic
society are issues that one does not
have to deal with in China I have to say
that there is a word in Chinese that
doesn't exist in any other language and
the word is called white it is what you
call a kid who listens to his or her
parents so I think we are very as a
people we are very quite we have this
sort of authoritarian figure that
Chinese always look up to and they do
expect the government to actually take
the actions and they will deal with it
however much suffering there is they
feel that okay if you know Big Brother
says that this has to be done then it
must be done and that really defines
China as a separate mentality Chinese as
has a separate mentality as say people
in Europe and America that sense of
collective responsibility sometimes
feels kind of a little absent from this
culture at the same time there are I
think valid concerns around surveillance
and kind of data privacy things like
that what is the balance here and what
is the right trade-off between
surveillance and freedom I think in the
Internet age it is somewhere between
China and the US I think when you take
individual freedom versus collective
safety there has to be a balance
somewhere there with surveillance you
know the the head of Baidu Robin Lee
once said the Chinese people are quite
willing to give up certain individual
rights in exchange for convenience
actually he was completely criticized on
Chinese social media but I think he is
right Chinese people are willing to give
up certain rights for example we have
Chinese mostly are very proud of the
payment system
we have which is we you can't go
anywhere just with your iPhone and pay
for everything and all they do is face
scan I think that probably freaks
Americans out you know China right now
we're still under semi lockdown so if
you go anywhere there's an app where you
scan and you input your mobile phone
number and the app will tell the guard
at the entrance of the mall for example
where you have been for the past 14 days
now when I told that to an American she
was horrified and she thought it was
such a invasion of privacy on the other
hand as someone who is Chinese and have
lived in China for the past twenty years
although I understand that America
mentality I still find it I'm Chinese
enough to think I don't mind this and I
am better I feel safer entering the mall
because everybody has as has been
scanned whereas I think individual
freedom as a abstract concept in a
pandemic like this is actually really
meaningless so I think the West really
need to move a step towards the east and
to think about the collective as a whole
rather than only think about oneself as
an individual the rise of antagonistic
rhetoric between the US and China is
obviously troubling and the thing is
that countries are interlinked whether
people understand global supply chains
or not where do you think we had next
you know this is this is the most
horrifying thing that came out of this
the kind of nationalistic sentiments on
both sides in this pandemic because I'm
an optimist I think what will come out
of this is that both sides will realize
that this is a fight that the entire
human race have to do together and not
apart despite the rhetoric the global
economy has grown to such a integration
that decoupling will be extremely costly
and painful for both the United States
and China it's also been interesting to
me to see the criticism that China has
received quite vocally for instance
they've been criticized for downplaying
the death toll arguably also for trying
to demonize dr. Lee the Wuhan doctor who
first kind of raised the alarm about the
corona virus I just saw a report in the
New York Times that Weibo users have
been posting repeatedly on the last post
of doctor Lee and kind of using this as
a kind of a living memorial to him and
chatting to him and there's something
like eight hundred and seventy thousand
comments and growing on that last post
do you see a change in the media do you
see a change in the approach to Chinese
leadership that actually could lead to
China swinging perhaps more to the
center just as perhaps America needs to
swing more towards a Chinese model
unfortunately not really because I think
though there is a way between
authoritarian governments and the people
and it's people to communicate the night
that dr. Lee died when it was announced
that he died the Chinese social media
just blew up even though he was unjustly
treated as a whistleblower he still went
to work in the hospital and try to save
lives as a doctor and then he died
because he contracted the disease so
there was anger frustration and all that
came out in kind of commemorating a
figure that they feel that the
government had wronged the verdict and
the sort of the official voice on who is
dr. Lee is he a good guy or bad guy
completely changed 180 degrees he went
from a doctor who misbehaved to the hero
who warned the people so I'm
Durrell thorat Aryan government they
they still are very aware of public
opinion but on the other hand when
people complain and when they
commemorate dr. Li do they really want
to change the system and my answer is no
because they don't like that particular
decision but they don't want to change
the system and one of the reasons is
because they have never ever known
another system this is the system they
know how to work
what is wok throwing Wong Oh wok
throwing is when you blame somebody else
basically someone who is responsible in
a slang Chinese is someone who carries a
black wok you are made to be the
scapegoat to be for something that is
bad so basically trumps start calling it
the Chinese virus the Wuhan virus and
naming trying to blame the entire
coronavirus pandemic on the Chinese and
then the Chinese I think through the
walk back at the American so it was like
a very funny joke on Chinese social
media that walk throwing there's a walk
throwing gymnastic aerobics exercise
video that went viral but Alice Wong
you're also doing dances on tick-tock
right oh of course I'm doing a lot of
walking I read aerobics tick-tock I mean
a potential silver lining of all of this
is that it has laid bare some of the you
know in inequities inequalities in the
system some of the broken structures
that we have and if we're smart we can
rebuild better yes I think one of the
silver linings of this pandemic is that
we do realize that human race have to do
something together rather than to be
distinguished by our race by the color
of our skin or by our nationality that
the virus obviously is not
discriminating against anyone whether
you're rich or poor important or not
important or whatever skin color or
nationality you are so it is a time to
be together rather than to try to pull
the world apart and crawl back to our
own nationalistic shells
it's a beautiful sentiment Quan hyung
thank you so much for joining us from
Beijing stay well please Thank You Helen
and you stay well as well
[Music]